it's been a month since germany's
general elections though the country
still doesn't have a new government it
does have a new parliament and today the
new parliament younger more female and
more ethnically diverse met in session
for the first time
germany's social democrats are now the
biggest party outgoing a chancellor
angela merkel will be formally released
from office though she will remain as
caretaker chancellor until a new
government is in place
let's have a look at how the new
parliament shapes up with
736 members the bundestag is now one of
the largest parliaments in the world and
it has never been this big more female
law makers were elected this time than
last time but women are still a long way
from reaching parity in numbers
more than a third of the new intake are
women including the first two trans
women to take seats
more than 11 percent of the incoming
lawmakers have migrant backgrounds three
percentage points up on last time
dw political correspondent nina hazard
joins us from the bundestag
welcome nina what has been happening in
this first session and what can we
expect
well today was obviously the beginning
of a new era in german politics with the
new bundestag holding its very first
session that is always exciting but uh
today it was particularly exciting
because it was also the beginning of the
end of the era of anglais merkel the
chancellor she sat on the viewers ranks
today she was here at the session but
because she did she decided to not a run
to not run again during this election
she had to take a back seat essentially
so the bundestag has now elected its new
president and all the deputies and
interestingly it went for the third
woman in post-war german history babel
buzz from the social democrats so the
role of the president always goes to the
party with the biggest group in the
parliament and that is this time around
the social democrats and later today
angela merkel and her ministers will
receive their formal documents releasing
them officially from their duties but
that government will stay in power as
caretaker government until the next
government is sworn in
so it's not just angela merkel uh
leaving though is it it's her party
leaving a leaving government after 16
years
and that's going to be a big change
isn't it
that is going to be a big change and
here to talk about exactly that what
does that mean for the conservatives to
go into opposition i have somebody from
the opposition from the cdu from the
conservatives thomas heinemann so how
are the cdu how are you going to shape
that role of opposition party you're not
used to it we're not used to it and we
don't like to use it to be used to it
now but we have to accept it
quite frankly we don't know how it will
go and
we have to learn it
you are a
digital expert angela merkel in 1999
declared you the honorary internet
expert of the cdu
and now 22 years later
germany is lagging behind when it comes
to digital infrastructure when it comes
to all things internet where did your
party go wrong
i mean
the the problem is that we have to
change the culture we have to change the
culture in the entire country so we i
talk about cities across our states and
we've got nationwide and and this
council change didn't take place
honestly and we needed to have corona to
be aware of it
um
and we now made big change changes um
but they don't you can't really see it
now but it will have a big change within
the next year so
this will go with a new government
yeah exactly that new government those
parties at least they have declared
digital all things digital one of their
top priorities along with a fight
against the climate crisis so what is
your role then why do we need the
conservatives what are the new
conservatives going to be which topics
will you
try and represent
some colleagues and myself we made an
initiative a year and a half ago called
neustar where we declare it has to be
the number one priority and what we have
to gonna do and we're pretty happy that
the new government said we want to
continue this project
and our role is known to control that
they really do so
okay well good luck with that good luck
with getting used to that new role of
opposition leader
thank you very much tomozam and you have
to run off to another meeting so we'll
let you go thank you very much for being
with us thank you
all right that was thomas heimann one of
the digital experts with the cdu the
conservatives and glomerulus
conservatives who are having to get used
to that new role of opposition party and
so with new parties trying to form a
government nina what sort of uh policies
can we expect from this parliament
well we've briefly touched upon it
already of course the social democrats
are now the biggest party group in the
new bundestag and
they have over taken over from the
conservatives they are currently in
negotiations in coalition talks with the
greens and the fdp
to form that new government that
hopefully will have by christmas and of
course they have a big majority here if
that
government actually comes together
between the social democrats the greens
and the ftp but they are not natural
allies so there are quite a few sticking
points still in those coalition talks
and they will go on for a couple of
weeks still but they all say that
they're optimistic that they'll overcome
the biggest hurdles and that we will
hopefully have a new chancellor a lead
government led by chancellor olaf
schultz by mid december all right thank
you for that dw political correspondent
nina haaser
so plenty of young first-time mps in
germany's new parliament dw uh
correspondent thomas sparrow met two of
them to hear about their hopes and
expectations
two fresh faces for the new german
parliament
and two very different political
realities
it's florian muller's first day as an mp
the 34 year old represents the center
right cdu party
does holding guns was on the attack
today is a very special day for me i
have been elected to the bundestag for
the first time gruelling an intense
campaign is behind me and now it's a
matter of actually becoming a proper mp
muller may be excited but his party is
in crisis
it had its worst ever result in
september's election and it's now
preparing for life in opposition after
16 years of leading the country with
angela merkel
that's our job not to be fundamentally
in opposition but to take a constructive
approach to ensure that this country is
well governed
riya schroeder's liberal fdp party knows
life in a position only too well
the 29 year old first-time mp is excited
this is too young it's of course
exciting to go into the plenary hall for
the first time now as a member of
parliament but i also feel a great
responsibility and i'm also honored to
be here
after four years in opposition the
liberals are currently in coalition
talks to join the next government
many young people voted for them and
that's particularly important for
schroder
i want to work to ensure that the
perspective of young people has an
impact here that the issues that are
important to young people education
climate protection digital development
are also on the agenda
muller
two new mps that stand for the profound
political change that is just beginning
to unfold as germany enters the post
merkel era